alors faut savoir que le poisson d'avril
de quartier qui est dit et bien entendu
autour de la tan à vous est ce que vous
avez une idée de qui est celui qui a
commis ce grave larcins c'était entre
16h30 et 17h kelly exactement on vous a
tous demandé avant l'émission nous
fournir un alibi
on va les vérifier ensemble et vous chez
vous vous avez mené l enquête sur
twitter http enquête
e n cul du e y
tout tout tout attention pas la boule
noire et crème la seule émission de son
élan vers d'autres et là on vient
d'entendre un cadreur mais éternuer de
ouf
[Applaudissements]
vous avez fait un look est avec nous et
celui qui trouvera alors le voile mais
ça sert non non non pour moi pas grâce à
ses mines iob il gagnera un an de
poissons sur la gueule sinon tu avais
pas que c'est une connerie
merci en tout cas pour vaud va essayer
d'être un ami peut redonner dans une
heure peut-être on va tout de suite
revoir la vidéo car on me dit que le son
est arrivé et vous allez voir qu'elle iv
novelli et ses tricks était très classe
s'en sont amers et voir si vous la
trouvez aussi glace avec du son à se
rendre à l'image assez bon
[Musique]
hall et or bas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
à qui vous en vouliez le plus à ce
moment là j'ai su qu'on avait fait en
cinq ans semble déjà reeves est pas
arrivé attendez attendez attendez oui
parce que j'étais dans le poisson vous
est contée manière attendait ne sais pas
je me pose la question ne s'est pas
voulu abandonner
oui et oui qui sait que si comme dans
qui a tué
roger ackroyd le meurtre de roger
ackroyd sauter quoi oui agatha christie
ne connaissent rien du tout adc roger
c'est pas un diacre et services est très
simple julia va mener l'enquêté avec moi
car julia est la seule personne en qui
j'ai une entière confiance autour de ces
interminables
la russie est le principal défaut de
beinheim sa fourberie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça peut être n'importe qui ici c'est
peut-être benhaim ça peut être salutaire
laurent voulzy ça peut être n'importe
qui ici castaldi où étiez-vous alors
mois par mois j'ai un alibi alors en or
je tournais pour vous dans l'essonne
dans un décor marocain magnifique avec
des chameaux civile et story on est neuf
ans de tp bris rocher vous avez vu les
swing ah oui franchement une belle
surprise qui vous attend pour jaillir et
j'ai toutes les images ont été postées à
16h sur mon instinct oui alors juste
deux minutes et parle à quelqu'un vous
faut vous discipliner pas pouvoir rester
alors vous avoir voyagé moi je vous le
dit
la preuve et d'assurance mon histoire
benjamin castaldi 16 heures j'étais dans
l'essonne ac/dc live et en direct
ah oui il a plu à le disculper à thulé
disculpe totalement rentré chez vous
merci vous êtes libre aux cascades
casque aldi et lidl vraiment libre
d'avoir un énorme scoop de mon
porte-à-porte alors oui vous l'aurez
tout à l'heure et pour l'instant vous
rentrez chez vous allez vous marier puis
vous revenez sur go à la faune ailée
benhaim oui whittier vous valérie benaïm
à valway wallon sait pas si choquant
comme tous les jours je préparais
évidemment avec énormément de méthode et
de sérieux c'est que de la télé c'est
que la télé mais la linaf et les
mystiques et de la télé ne se
tourne-t-il pas dans les studios
connaîtront pas les studios ici là il
était sur les lieux du crime
j'étais effectivement sur les lieux des
crimes mais j'étais à côté de kelly au
maquillage est alors très bien vous
l'utilisez aux coiffures de mettre ce
coaching de poisson mais n'empêche c'est
que lorsque je finis je parle
immédiatement brief avec mes équipes
benhaim on a vu des tas de votre
émission n'est pas faite brief
aujourd'hui elle en lui me fait pas le
faire julia pour l'instant je crois que
beinheim va rester avec nous d'accord
moi j'ai beaucoup confiance en elle et
merci génial ça se dit sûr mais
qu'également la vegetal moi c'était la
balle à excuser moi je suis vous êtes
victime c'est beaucoup moins aujourd'hui
vont bien c'est bon pardon mais bien
bronzé ce week-end ouais merci
non mais c'est vrai parce que vous avez
fait mais bravo vous étiez où quelque
part photo couverture hier on ne riait
pas jardin d'accord l'aristocratie
madame charbonneau bélisle a dit oui
bientôt sur netflix jean michel maire
vous étiez ou bas j'étais chez moi j'ai
malheureusement pas de témoins j'étais
seule avec mon chien qui faisait quoi
j'étais en train de préparer l'émission
entre avec nous je crois pas du tout
c'est maxime gainey jeu le suspectent
énormément c'est vrai j'étais 15
rigoureux et comprend même pas les goûts
je suis venu travailler en amont ici
dans ce studio allons travailler dans ce
studio ici c'est dieu vous étiez sur les
lieux du crime
kenny guennoun regardez bien écrire
qu'est-ce que vous ne manquerez peintre
regardez vous dénoncez mélo donner de
numéro un mais non
[Applaudissements]
pour les téléspectateurs je détiens une
nouvelle pièce à conviction de l'antenne
ça me paraît naturel que va faire le
buzz
[Musique]
c'est du bon boulot ça vous atteler
breguet ni rentrer chez vous c'est
pourquoi des missions à faire consiste à
compter
c'est pour moi c'est pour vendre
aguerris dont 3 18e chaque côté 1 on est
pas c'est pas ici à evry excusez moi
monsieur maurice l'air d'être très
honnête avec vous ma j'étais de retour
d'un tournage pour le prime de jeudi
mais il n'est pas de photos pas
d'éléments visuels
j'ai pas de preuves je n'ai que mon
honnêteté gilles verdez mais quand vous
êtes habillé vous avez dû passer
beaucoup de temps merci l'isthme êtes
donc disculper rentrer chez fat ou
[Applaudissements]
l'inspecteur anna vous apparemment vous
étiez trop occupé à mettre des bijoux
vous pouvez directement chez vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
raymond mon ami raymond à la même ok mon
ami mais bon je suis tout de suite si
moment tchimou dit la vérité je le
connais depuis des années que ça va être
réglé en livraison j'étais en pleine
campagne et j'ai même failli vous
envoyer un texto pour lire je peux pas
venir ce soir parce que je suis dans une
louise internationale six mois ça peut
être moins pourquoi êtes vous venu je
suis bien parce que j'avais fini les
livraisons et je me suis couché là où
vous êtes touché là où ça va les
chercher chez lui à poil sept personnes
au cou c'est douchy suivante qu'est ce
que vous voulez ouais on vous a reconnu
merci merci que vous êtes très sympa
rentrez chez vous allez allez faire un
jeu de 7 familles vraiment vous êtes
disculper rentrez chez vous raymond
[Applaudissements]
girardi mailly alors qu'ils sortent
cissé gignac au mazet qui maillent j'ai
un point commun avec vous cyril lecler
sortie ni herges peaufiner mon jeu de
jambes et aujourd'hui entre 16h et 17h30
j'ai lu le livre de valérie orsini sur
le gainage on veut bien sûr et
d'ailleurs j'ai une preuve mais c'est
vrai un valérie orsini objectif ventre
plat que signifie cette mascarade
il fait le coureur d'ailleurs vous avez
pas de problème de vente mais c'est
toujours bien d'être gêné tout étonné
que vous payez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pour l'instant c'est vexant vous êtes
les deux qui me semblent coupable
peut-être vous cher monsieur alors là si
c'est déjà je ne vous reconnais pas qui
êtes vous et vous tu faisais la sienne
on faisait la sieste
oui vous allez on le croit pas discuter
sa chaire est chez vous le coupable est
là dans ce périmètre
mais j'aimerais savoir avant quelle est
la sanction pour le coupable la sanction
à une bonne sanction quand même s'il
vous plaît quand vous serez capable de
mettre des sanctions quand vous aurez
pour le faire on vous appellera d'accord
alain pour le moment vous allez faire un
petit peu de vélo dont vous rappellera
mais deux jours je t'aime pas lui faut
le suivre à ses machines de guerre c'est
une machine cette machine de guerre qui
a dit oui
v novelli la même d'ailleurs je ne vous
appelle pas qu'il y là c'est l'enquêteur
qui parlait la victime
et oui d'ophélie tu ne voulais pas que
suis victime quand même pas dire que je
me fais agresser pitt a pris cinq
douches oui mais je vous dis plus ça va
plus on commence à ne plus supporter la
victime avait le coupable c'est l'un des
deux ouais
julia qui est le coupable pour vous jean
michel jean michel maire vous proposer
qu'on revoie les images et il reste deux
possibles
agresseurs benhaim et jean-michel mais
un scoop ou revoir les images de qualité
de vie y est vous avez été très nombreux
à réagir sur twitter c'est parti je ne
vous aime pas
[Musique]
hall et tarbes à hadopi
voilà donc à étaient déguisées en lady
gaga elle s'est vite transformé en lady
keira médias algériens 10,1 ses marges
si vous avez dit non caudry médias car
oui c'est pas très beau non vous êtes
très drôle malheureusement pas dans
l'émission alors hama qui a fait ça mais
naim ou jean michel maire
kelly à votre avis qui vous agresser ses
deux grosses suspicion pour valérie
benaïm mais je serais extrêmement déçu
alors va naître tu vas être extrêmement
alors ben moi je pense que c'est valve
malade et d'animaux non benhaim benhaim
qui traduit la cab et des innus non je
peux pas dire par julien vous pensez que
c'est qu'ils vous vous avez dit
jean-michel ouimet ce que je te crois
que c'est ça non plus mais ça serait
vraiment une déconvenue et bien sûr
écouter offre six mois je vais vous dire
je sais qu'il est coupable
vous le savez d'une début bien entendu
le tas partir du moment où je suis
rentré dans cette salle mon fils m'a
guidé par là
dans ce périmètre dans ce
parallélépipède rectangle abcd avec la
bissectrice je ne vous aime pas benhaim
un mois des riches je vous aime pas non
je vous alors moi je vous adore on a les
images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
vérité